foreign
[Music]
asking women to contribute to the table
is a shamelessness I do not possess
quote tweet masculinity is too toxic for
all of that I'd rather liquidate all my
assets
the bread and said the whole thing
yeah the bread yeah bro I'd rather
liquidate my assets than ask a chick to
contribute to this table
when you first were speaking I I don't
know why but when you said table and I
thought restaurant oh okay the more you
spoke I realized club and I was like oh
um
asking for a girl to contribute for this
club table no way no oh I would always
yeah and it's not even
do you guys ever do guys ever say no I'm
sorry I have a girlfriend reply if
someone offers you money do you say no I
have a salary
[Laughter]
Prof facts at the end of the day facts
like what are we doing facts and what
are we actually doing
oh that's funny I'm so glad the music
and the club be loud because I'll be
farting and [ __ ]
that's disgust that is disgusting fam I
promise you now there's not a single
thing worse than smelling pop in a club
oh it's just musty it's you and you
don't have a clue who the cause is it
hits you so hard humid bro and you just
you you hate everyone everyone [ __ ]
hate everyone and then you look at a
painting and then you're like if it came
from you I swear to God
I'm gonna start throwing hands because
it hits you as if it was targeted for
you oh it's one million thanks in the
club and everyone you're looking at them
and they're looking at you
[ __ ] you it's not me and then you have
to go outside
the [ __ ] is that now who's back is hot
who's buying something you're trying to
yeah yeah smell that
well you know that
[ __ ] sake uh I hate uh actually that's
I'm sorry that's really pissing me off
it's the most badass thing it's very
important because a club wants to be a
pristine experience yeah yeah yeah I
want to smell perfume and lollipops
I just want to smell perfume and
lollipop facts and see sparkles and [ __ ]
and smelling pop ruins it ruins the
whole of it especially if you're like an
underground club or saying oh you're
very aware of where you're at yeah yeah
yeah it's sweat and pop oh it's
disgusting it's terrible
I'm gonna be in my daughter here like go
tell Dad we want Chick-fil-A yeah
that's funny but that's hilarious
daughters can manipulate Daddy can we go
to Chick-fil-A please have Chick-fil-A
please Daddy please oh please daddy
you're the [ __ ] all right good go tell
Daddy we want Chick-fil-A that's
hilarious oh [ __ ] sake and she's just
there smiling in a restaurant yeah yeah
yeah whatever
my son is gonna be mad when I name him
Garrett in Brackets short for cigarette
wow short for cigarettes
that's jokes that is funny my cousin was
going back to Nigel idea why day
yesterday my cousin were going back to
night yesterday but his flight was
delayed because someone got deported and
decided to poo smear all over the plane
they got deported so they stood up and
was like [ __ ] [ __ ] this and just like
smearing [ __ ] all over everywhere all
over the place I was like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
this country [ __ ] these laws everywhere
I'm not going back
tweet quote tweet
tweet text me back or I'm not taking my
meds
quick tweet Kim K checking her phone in
the morning
bro
[Applause]
she's exhausted with him text me back or
I'm not taking my meds wow that's the
threat James
that's a threat bro
too funny she she's going through it
there's a level of toxicity that women
secretly love but he's way over here
there's nothing sexy about what he's
doing he's just lost his mind he's
literally lost his mind we speak about
it all the time he's going through [ __ ]
yeah he's continuously going through
this done to school he's doing oh what's
that you've never heard of his done to
school no he's done to school he's got a
school called donda for for who for you
bro just it's a school is it a music
school it's a school bro do we not have
enough schools fam um all I know is
country is it in America of course it's
not open any more schools in America
there's open no one wants to go to your
Yeezy done to school fam done to school
yeah he said he wants to take his kids
out of the school he's got there already
out and bring him to Don no one cares
what you want to do leave your kids your
kids are at a prestigious private school
your kids are probably one of the best
schools in the country in the world
probably live aware facts donder school
bags their kids these kids are fed up
these kids are fed up what's the oldest
one called North she's pissed off
because she's she's the only one that
can actually have conversation proper
conversations
I'm annoyed now yeah I'm actually yeah
that was cute it's [ __ ] annoying stop
it was every day White lives matter did
you really need to say that did you
really need to I know you're a little
tension [ __ ] but I've got friends I've
got friends everywhere I've Got Friends
and they've got eyes stop why am I
having to defend you
in the cafeteria every day Dad
you're rich as [ __ ] he's just he's
ruining lives bro okay anyway
this is back to back actually I know
[ __ ] be scared to text Kanye back
[ __ ] post everything
he actually he posts everything and
reprising caps lock
he replies everything in caps lock it's
actually mad to think that like you
could think that you and him are super
cool and then the next day you just see
it you're just on his page you're just
on his page and you're like you're
probably like the second slide that's a
[ __ ] yeah why is he beating me out like
bro he was he was big enough Diddy the
other day and then he said [ __ ] you to
him the next day something like that I
can't keep up with him bro rags
some chick tweeted when he when he sucks
the [ __ ] only oh you must want a key
made
yeah we
oh you must want a key made oh Madness
that's that Sensei Oh indeed Jesus told
my boyfriend I was out with my mum he
didn't he don't know that Mum stands for
my other man
I'm pretty sure you've read that one
before I haven't I've read something
similar oh okay
I remember I can't remember what it is
but red side is very similar my other my
mother man
I think I think you'll never find that
out
never
my grandma lies so much talking about
she used to babysit Jeffrey Dahmer
yo yo that's funny she lies so much oh
Jesus that's actually hilarious
foreign
calls out brace yourself darling just
before he orgasms he cannot understand
why I never want to [ __ ] him again
brace yourself brace yourself darling
I'm coming into land
brace yourself from your home to roost
brace yourself it's gonna be a rocky nut
it's gonna be a rocky nut
oh oh yuck
I want to meet the Tom that got an
entire genre of fully renamed after him
makes sense it doesn't stupid it took a
second to sing it and I was like I saw
your eyes I saw your
wondering like that Zach better that
meme
and you have to hold the smell like yeah
okay yeah the whole Foolery what oh yeah
yeah I'll say that
don't get in my car telling me how to
drive sit back and hold on tight
yeah right
if the sex come without head you can
keep it I ordered a [ __ ] combo
asked him for his height he's been
typing for two minutes oh my God
he's been typing for two minutes just
bubble bubble stop bubble down bubble
down oh he don't know what to do with
what to say
for two minutes oh
Peak very Peak
um
next one pulled out so far she started
spitting like a Beyblade
all right sweet quotes for you
Kris Jenner claims she never knew Bruce
was uncomfortable having sex with her
and thought he was kidding when he
loudly booed her vagina
nah bro
yuck
who ordered the serpenter oh stop it get
that away from me get that away from me
jokes that's jokes so slippy
tweet reply reply
wow just saved my nan ain't this start
again wow just shade for nothing ain't
this a [ __ ] reply come see me don't let
it go to waste reply too late I glued it
back on
don't let it go to waste oh my God I
know for a fact there's a certain type
of woman that would take up that offer
oh Rags shaven Takes a Minute it does no
legs
that's a turtle don't leg go to here
don't let it go to waste too late I
glued it back on I might if I was the
brother that sent that risque reply and
then she's two letter glued it back on
oh I'm deleting tweet on Twitter I'm
deleting Twitter
why are you rubbing up ruining why are
you ruining this quotation [ __ ] sake
it took a lot for me to send that rags
fine
last one I don't know I feel like Mike
Myers would let me walk away and live my
vibe is just different
there's so many people that actually
think they're different they're so
stupid James
different
[Laughter]
[Music]